haird. He's short. But just know that
your Lord is not one eyed. He is
oneeyed, but Allah, he's not oneeyed.
That's how you can tell the difference.
Okay. All right. So, they're virtually
identical. Mhm. They're identical. You
see where this is coming from? Because
they believe God, do you not? No.
Because you believe God is a man. You
This is why I don't blame you. Because
Because you believe God is a man, you
have to apply that to everything you
see. All you see is the Trinity. All you
see is fully man, fully God. Let me tell
you, let me tell you what. Because
you've looked at the narration that says
hair and this that you're thinking,
"Hey, we believe God is a man." Hair,
eyes. Oh my gosh, that sounds like
Jesus. Oh no. Muslims believe in that as
well. Nice try. Why would I do this? You
don't believe he has curly hair. Why do
this though? Can you imagine? Muslim, do
you believe Allah has curly hair? No. I
don't care about what they believe. I
care about what the hadith. Guys, guys,
guys, please. Well, this is this is your
best argument. No, but I'm I'm talking
to you. You're not what I'm saying. Did
you come all the way from America? I
came all the way with this curly
argument. I came all your arguments are
curly. I need to straighten them out.
Okay, good.
I am a Rever and I was taught how to
pray salah. That means every single time
I pray, the person who told me gets the
reward five times a day from fud to Isa.
If you want to support someone like me
in learning salah, then sponsor 10
people for just £100 this Ramadan.
Remember the prophet peace be upon him
said, "Charity does not decrease wealth.
Click the button and donate now.
Look at this. That's the first one. I
hope you don't run. I hope you don't
run. Just saying. I hope [__] You
sent the message, bro. Little [__]
This little [__] intellectual [__]
Thank you. Intellect. Intellectual.
Intellectual [__] Already insulting.
You know, intellectual [__] Dominion.
I'm going to run from you. I'm going to
run from you. Alhamdulillah, bro. You
think you think we don't know you guys
are there? Aldah. Yeah. Just don't run
away. Alhamdulillah. Brother, packing
up, brother. The only one that's going
to pack up is you. You're going to pack
up yourself, mate. You're going to pack
up. We'll see. Alhamdulillah, bro. Bro,
anyone that believes in the trinity, you
don't fear. I don't I don't fear you one
bit, bro. Anyone that believes in the
trinity, bro, bro. Anyone that believes
in the trinity is the weakest person
ever, bro. Intellectually, spiritually,
mentally, physically. Does Allah have a
soul? Alhamdulillah, bro. Allah, can you
imagine? Allah has a soul. Does he have
a spirit? Can you imagine? Does he have
a spirit? This guy thinks we have the
trinity.
Trinity. No. No. He's like, he's like a
little jazz. Where is he? Where are
Where's the team? Where the team?
Where's the team? Don't worry. There.
Don't worry. Where is it? There. Where
are they? Don't worry. Just don't run.
Alhamdulillah. Alhamdulillah. Don't run
when they get here. Alhamdulillah. Call
him. Alhamdulillah. To test. Scared of
intellectual. Alhamdulillah. We're doing
fundraising. You going to say that about
though? What's this one? Is this one?
All right. Scam artist.
Let's do some fundraising. Look at these
guys. We're doing some fundraising. Scam
artists. Listen guys. Scam artist. Just
donate. scam artist. Just donate, guys.
He's Guys, guys, should I donate so they
can learn how to play like Jesus? I tell
him not to not to send money to the scam
artist. Jesus. Yeah, I mean like Jesus.
Look, so you teach me how to pray. You
admitted that 219 scientific evidence
has been debunked.
Say 219. Alhamdulillah, the Quran Islam
is there's no scientific evidence.
There's no need came to Israel.
scientific evidence is an has been
debunked. Say it. Alhamdulillah. Islam
is an Italian. It has been debunked.
Carry on debunked. Carry on donating.
Come on. Donate to the scam artist.
Carry on
donating. He's supporting Ham and
terrorist organizations. No, we know. We
know. 6,000 years. Allah have a spirit.
Alhamdulillah.
Does Allah have brothers and sisters?
Brothers and sisters. Does Allah have a
spirit? Huh? No. He's helping me
fundraise. Yeah. Intellectual [__]
That's how he calls me. Yes. Yes. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah, spiritually, mentally. He
don't call women that emotionally. He
don't call that. Let's go. Come on.
Let's go, brothers and sisters. Like
about to school you on your own, guys.
Guys, carry on donating. Allah have a
spirit. Just carry on donating. What
does it say? Alhamdulillah. You want to
read it for me? Sisters, just carry on
donating. Yes. We're teaching people
Christians who come to Islam how to
pray. What does it say? With a carry on
donating. What does it say? Carry on
donating. Alhamdulillah. Carry on
donating. He's my co-undrazer.
Listen.
Carry on donating. Let's see. Good. Can
I have Can I have the laptop here,
please? I want the laptop here. Yeah,
cuz we need We're going to have live
updates now. We're going to have live
updates. I'm telling you concentrate
over there. No, no. I I need to know the
donation, bro. Cuz you know what? I'm
going to use it. Yes. Go to go to go to
the donation. That's all I need. Forget
this now. Oh, sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Just
forget just go here. You're excited,
huh? Yeah. Yeah. Just leave this. No,
no, no. Where's it? This one. Yeah. Has
it? That's all I need. Yeah. Leave with
that. Yes. Cuz when get the chat what I
need cuz you know what? It's about to
kick off. So, alhamdulillah. What we
need is this, bro. We just need people
to donate and we're going to use this
against. Alhamdulillah. Look, you're a
scam artist. Alhamdulillah. 200 £219.
We're £219 away. Look at this guys. What
are you doing with all the money? £29.
What are you doing with the money?
Alhamdulillah. I don't get paid a penny.
What do you do with the money? I don't
get paid a penny. You pay taxes? I heard
you don't pay taxes. Yes, I pay taxes. I
spoke to the tax man. Oh, yeah. You when
I paid I spoke to him two weeks ago. Two
weeks ago. I paid my tax. Oh, because
you got You got caught on camera. I paid
too much tax. You got caught on camera.
Now with 200 and 90 away. Alhamdulillah.
Help the scam artist.
You are not giving him time to speak.
You're not giving him. He's a coward.
Oh, you call me intellectual. He's a
coward. Call me inellectual. He calls me
an intellectual [__] Yes, you are.
You're intellectual. I'm about to cook
you.
250. Alhamdulillah. Alhamdulillah.
We're hit 20,000 today.
We're going to hit 20,000 today.
May Allah keep you steadfast.
Alhamdulillah.
Bo, the only thing I need is this right
now. When they come, this is what I
need. Because you know what's going to
happen? They're going to donate me this.
I'm telling you, you can go there. Look,
that's just going to look you can, but
I'm just saying when they come, this is
what I need. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You can
check now, but when when no logic comes,
I need this. That's all I need. What do
you what is your question? I got a
question. Really? He won't let me ask a
question though. 10 times. He said he
got cooked every time. The intellectual
cooked you every time. It means he has
got no intellectual. You're yelling
right now. He's yelling right now. But I
can't yell. Brother, I'm a doctor. I'm a
surgeon. What does that mean? It proves
I have got intellectual capacity. So,
can I ask a question? Yes. Please go on.
I can ask question. What did you say? He
has no intellectual capacity. He doesn't
have intellectual capacity.
He is raising he is raising his voice
continuously without giving the other
person voice right now. Click the bank.
Oh, so you're not raising your voice.
$1. Can I ask the question? Donate for
the sake of Allah. Guys, can I ask the
question? Allah works in mysterious
ways. Can I ask the question? Allah says
in the Quran, you might hate something
which is good for you. It's good for the
charity. We're going to print more mats.
Come on. Can I ask you what? For the
Christians who come to Islam, we teach
them how to pray salah. Ask a question.
We teach them how to pray salah.
I can look guys.
Look guys, look. Wait, I said
intellectual. I said intellectual, not
literal. Okay, he
got you. I'm talking about Listen.
Listen. You can be this and be
intellectual. [__] where he help you?
Listen. Where's Where's no logic?
Where's no logic? He'll be here soon.
Where's no logic? Don't run. No logic.
Logic will be here soon. Don't run. No
logic. Don't run. Please watch him run.
Tell him to come, bro. Tell him to come.
Tell him to come. Tell us. Would you
have a conversation? No logic. No logic.
Would you have a conversation? Bring him
here. I need him. No. But would you have
a conversation? Bring him here. Would
you have a conversation? Bring him here.
Cuz I would like to hear the
conver here. You see? Bring him here.
You see? Bring him. Tell him. Tell him.
Tell him. Tell him. The Orthodox Muslim
that smashed him is going to be on the
phone. Orthodox Muslim. He's been
running away from that from that debate
from the Orthodox Muslim. The Orthodox
Muslim destroyed him. Annihilate him.
Alhamdulillah. Tell him to come here.
No, tell him to come here. Bro, hold on.
Wait. Come here. But would you would you
chat to him? Come here. You chat to him.
Tell him to come here. Look, another 10
10 year old monotheism supporter speed
monism. 10. Alhamdulillah. He's not
telling him to come here. No logic. No
logic. I know you're watching. No logic.
Come here. No logic. Alhamdulillah.
We are 954 away. Bro, I already said it
to I don't know if myself we're 954
away. Brothers and sisters, carry on.
Donham, we are here. We ain't going
nowhere, brother. We're here, brother.
Anyone that believes in the trinity is
weak emotionally, intentionally,
intellectually, physically, spiritually.
I'll never run away from my trinitarian,
brother. Never ever. 954.
Someone believes in 954. They are weak.
They are weak. Anyone that believes God
became a man is a weak person. Why? Why
would anyone that believes the one who
created the heavens and the earth became
a man is weak. Okay. But if it's the
Quran, the word of God, it's weak. The
word of God. Of course, the word of God.
It's clear. It's clear. It's word of
God. Alhamdulillah. Yes. Unchanged and
alhamdulillah. Is it? Alhamdulillah. Is
it alhamdulillah? There you go. Is it Is
it guys guys look at look guys look at
this. Look
how
no why
logic what logic is this? No logic mine
are you Muslim? No I'm not. Why is your
name? My name is cuz my dad's Muslim and
I was Muslim and I became a Christian.
So no logic sent you here just to test
the waters out. No
no logic. Come on bro. Come on.
£954. Come on. Come on. Come on. I say
God
judges no. Let me let me And we've got
now a Muslim became a Christian. It's
not going to work. It's not going to
work. Brothers and sisters,
£954 away. We've got £374 people
watching. 954, guys. Donate for the sake
of Allah. Just give me one minute.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I'm continuing.
We just need nine people to do 100. I
know ten commandments. What are they?
Tell them to donate. Tell them. What are
the ten commandments? What are the ten
commandments? What is it? You tell me.
You tell me. No, you tell me. He doesn't
know what they are. You tell me. Tell me
what they are. Why would you explain?
Can you explain to him? Which one of
those? Do you believe in? I call them.
Do you believe in Mus? Yes. Do you
believe in Alhamdulillah? Do you believe
in the Alhamdulillah? Do you believe in?
Alhamdulillah. Yes. Donate. Donate to
Allah. We are going to raise. We are
going to teach Christians who are coming
to Islam how to pray salah. Do you
believe in
Alhamdulillah? Let's go. Brothers and
sisters, look sir, just answer. Do you
believe in the Do you know how many
Christians learn how to pray salah? They
were Christians. They Muslim now. Do you
know how many? Alhamdulillah. Answer.
Alhamdulillah. Let's go.
Answer. Let's go. Let's go.
Let's go. Let's go. Right now.
£954 some powerful donation.
Alhamdulillah. Do you believe in the ten
commandments? Alhamdulillah. Guys, we
are a registered charity. Not a single
pound comes to me. Uncle your uncle.
Let's go. Let's go. Let's go.
We're waiting for no logic.
Right. Where's the no logic? Where's no
logic? Where's no logic? Where's no
logic? Do you believe in a limit?
Where's no logic? I just heard that. Why
would you
answer? Let's go. Let's go. Let's go.
Let's go. You guys do ma. Let's talk
about the ten commandments first. Okay.
Let's talk about the talk about Let's
go. £100.
£100. Yeah. I know. I know. 100.
Alhamdulillah. Alhamdulillah. What you
say, brother? What you saying? No logic.
No logic. Nice to meet you. No logic.
How you been? No logic. For the whole
crew. For the whole crew. You know, of
course, man. I look short on videos cuz
next to Muhammad hijab everyone look
short you look short next to me you like
what I yeah something like the 188 we're
doing we're doing a bit we're doing a
bit of fundraiser and I thought I need a
I need I need a co- funraiser you need a
fundraiser yeah fundraiser we need
fundraising Christian help us with it
yeah you're going to help me come we're
going to work together come so we got
this matt where's our m guys
he's helping our hamas let's see how I
like hummus I like hummus hummus hummus
not Hamas what is it okay so this let me
tell you about it yeah Uh-huh. You see
this is a guided prayer mat. Okay. Yeah.
Can I get this on your camera so your
camera don't want to miss it? Yo yo my
friend, move out the way. So we got a
prayer mat. Okay. So So now there's
something that's familiar to you though.
I'm your friend now. So if you don't
mind, you might hold it here. I
appreciate it. Okay. When Jesus went to
the mount of Gethsemane. Uh-huh.
Did he do something like this to the
father? He prayed. He prayed to his
father. They said
Yeah. Yeah. He prostrated to his father.
How How does that look like? Oh, he just
bowed his head on the ground actually.
Was it was it was it about like this
like when RKU or was it like this? I
don't I don't know. Which one would you
say? Do you think it was more like
bowing ru? I think they I think it was
probably laid out flat on the ground
actually. Flat? Yeah, like full flat.
Yeah, probably full face on the ground.
Where'd you get that from? Cuz it says
he fell down. He fell out on the floor.
No, I don't feel but like to say that.
I'm not trying to be funny. To say that
sometimes I have that. Yeah, they they
were on the floor sometimes in the Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. I don't know about that.
Yeah. I think most likely we have this
this is called or I would say yeah when
one of those two because the thing is
the act of for example when you're
forward when you're laying flat down
yeah even that's it's more humbling it's
more humbling but I would just say me
personally I would say this or these two
but that's besides the issue so this is
a guided prayer mat you do you think
that Jesus prayed like this yeah no not
no I wouldn't I don't know if exactly
like this would have evidence to that
but I would say something like this or
this but let me tell you about our
charity so we're a charity you trying to
relate it to Jesus No, no, no, no, no,
no, no. That's off topic. That's off
topic. So, where where a charity? That's
the point. Yeah. No, that's right. We're
a charity. I don't get paid a single
penny cuz there, you know, there's a
lot. You know, I see that Christian guy
who bought a jet, Jesus jet. No, you
know that guy who's he looks a bit
scary. He bought a jet for Jesus. Like
20 weirdo. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. I say he's a widow as well.
So, we're raising funds cuz what we do
is we teach people how to pray. We have
a guided prayer, man. We give for free,
by the way. All of our service teach
them to pray like Jesus. Yeah. That's
what we do. The Christians that come to
Islam like praying like Jesus. Look,
they even learn how to do woodoo. But
hold on. Yeah. Yeah. Of course. Of
course. Especially I've been I've been
waiting for you. This This is I've been
waiting for you. You should teach them
to pray like Jesus. Yeah. But look look.
Look, let me let me just tell you about
the project so you understand so your
viewers can understand what we're doing.
We understand what you're doing. No, no,
not me. Not me. Not me. The project. Let
me tell you about the project. Okay. But
the the project is the wrong way. You
got to take before we go before we go
the wrong way. Let me tell you about
what we do. So we have a charity. Yeah.
I'm a I'm I'm I'm part part of the
charis. I'm a volunteer. I don't get
paid. Yeah. Okay. You don't get paid? I
don't get paid a single penny. Yeah. So,
what we do is we have a couple of
projects. The first one is we have
guided prayer mats. The one I showed you
and we have them like this. So, we print
them in like uh different different
languages. So, this year we're printing
them 50,000 in Italian, German, French,
Spanish, Portuguese, Albanian, and in
English. How does that how does that
help them learn about and pray like
Jesus? I'll tell No, I didn't. No, no. I
said Jesus prayed something similar to
that. There's nothing like that. No,
that's a different topic. I'm just
telling you about the charity. Forget
look Islam Christianity. We're talking
about the charity now. That's what this
is about Islam. Let me let me finish. So
So let me finish. So this the first
thing that's in the mat is this guided
shows you how to do woo cuz we need to
do abition. You know we need to do
abition before we pray. Yes. You know
that. Yeah. Yeah. You know that. Okay.
So then what we do is we give them a
guided prayer mat for free. Yeah. So
what they do is because we have a lot of
converts that come to Islam. Yeah. A lot
of Christians they come to Islam. We
teach them how to pray salah. What about
the ones that leave? Um Yeah. Yeah. The
one like you're talking about Apos.
Okay. So, so, so another another thing
we have is we have an app that's coming
out soon. Yeah. It looks at me like this
cuz you know guys, I'm sharing the first
time with knowledge Christian prayer.
Oh, really? Yeah. And he says it's a
Jesus prayer. Oh, I didn't know that.
Well, that's that's deep actually. One
second. Can I ask you a quick question?
What What was he before you came to
Islam? Christian. Is that how long you
been a Muslim? 17 years. 17 years. He
was a Christian before. Showing you how
orthodox Christians pray. Yeah.
According to Jesus prayer, this is how
he prayed. So why why then why do you
say the Muslims were like Jesus? No no
no we believe look he just showed us
look Jesus love that's an orthodox. So
it's kind of like Muslims got it from
the orthodox Christians. No no no we
were saying that they probably prayed
similar way because we believe Islam was
there from the the day from Adam. But
you wouldn't say that they were Muslims.
Let's watch it. Let's watch this first.
Let's see. You wouldn't say that they're
Muslims. No. Every prophet is a Muslim.
No I mean like the Orthodox Christians
out there proating there doing the No,
of course not. But if he's praying like
Jesus, he's got it from scripture. Okay.
I don't know. I don't know where you got
the whole thing from, guys. Let's see.
Some of the prophets will lay out just
lay out full out and some of the priests
as well. I I don't know. That's what he
showed me. Anyways, let's go back to our
app. So, this is our app. Just show for
the Where's your camera? Is this your
camera? Which one's your camera? This
your camera? No, that's our camera.
Okay. This one. So, for uh this guy's uh
channel. This our app. It's coming out
in a week's time. It's been about a year
and a half. Yeah. So, it also has a
kibla finder. You know, some people face
Jerusalem, we have to find face kibla.
So, it shows you it's free. It's free.
It's free. By the way, what does it got
to do with Jesus? I'll tell you. I'll
tell you. I'll tell you. I'm doing I'm
doing marketing here. Yeah. How does
this help somebody with the truth? Let
me tell you how this helps with the
truth. So, if somebody wants to book a a
a um instructor to teach them how to
pray, they can go and book it for free.
But what does that got to do with them
finding truth? How come? Like if they're
if you're telling them how to go through
the motion cuz when they cuz when they
accept Islam and they come to the truth,
then we need to tell them other pillars
of Islam. The second pill of Islam is
prayer. So, you can order a guided
prayer mat in America around the world.
The mat is for free. We don't charge
you. It's free. They have to pray this
way. Just one thing. One one thing.
Yeah. We also work with local mosques.
Dude, I
understand. Just one second. I'm going
to explain. Yeah. Okay. These are these
are salah hugs. You can learn how to
create salah. Now, not only that, we
also have video tutorials how to pray.
Okay. So, now brothers and sisters, the
reason I'm doing this is because we're
doing a bit of fundraising. We've had
some donations as you can see here. What
does that have to do
with it's it's a holy month. Yeah. So,
we've raised £100. The hot 50 look
pounds and 20, but you got to be in the
hop. Can you do a shout out to the
Americans to donate? Can you do a shout
out to the Americans to donate? Look,
Americans, look. Yeah, I got you.
Americans, if they're teaching you about
Jesus and the gospel, and they teach you
how to pray like Jesus, calling God as
father, right? If they're teaching, if
they're praying like Jesus, go ahead and
donate. If they're not praying like
Jesus, then don't donate for the gospel.
You know, you know, you know, you know
what's interesting? In Ramadan, do you
remember was driving? A Christian
donated
£534. Yeah. We was a bit taken back cuz
we don't we don't usually get that. So,
we was we was going to go pray Isa. So,
we stopped in a service station and then
I went we went to pray and we was live
streaming. A Christian donated. We don't
know why, but £534. And Allah tells us
in the Quran, the Christians are not the
same. There's good and there's bad.
Okay? And they're close to us. So, and
there was another guy who get donated.
He was also a Christian. So to us,
alhamdulillah, the Christians that are
close to us, we have no problem with
them. We only have issue with the
hostile ones. Okay? The ones who are
hostile, the ones who lie, the ones who
cheat, the ones who And then they're not
the same. Do you get it? There are good
Christians, there are bad Christians,
there are good Muslims, there are bad
Muslims. So we want to appreciate the
Christian community because
alhamdulillah they live with the Muslims
side by side for centuries.
Alhamdulillah. Yeah. So Allah tells us
in the Quran that we are close to the
Christians, they are we can marry from
them. We can eat from their meat.
Alhamdulillah. We have protected them
for many centuries across other
denominations who are persecuting them.
So my question is alhamdulillah if
you're teaching
who someone just donated £500
my question but one second £500 teaches
50 to 150 people to learn how to pray
salah by the way. Yeah, bro
£500 if we get if we can get 15 grand
that fantastic question £50,000. If you
have if you're teaching them how to pray
with a prayer man this prayer man. Yeah.
What is the point of teaching them how
to pray this way if this is wrong? If
it's not untruth. I don't know. Of
course, because the thing is this is the
second pillar. What's the second pillar
of Islam? I don't know. What's the
second pill? You don't want me to show
you. Come on, man. You know, I don't
know. Smart. Come on. You've been You
You study Islam more than you study
Bible. You don't know the second pillar
of Islam. I'll give you I'll give you a
clue. I'll give you a clue. I don't know
what that is. What was we talking about?
What am I talking about all this time?
Well, I don't voodoo, man. Brother, what
do you think? I don't know. Man, what
prayer? Yes. Okay, that's the second
pill. I thought you know it. I thought
you know five pillars at least. Yeah.
The second pill of Islam. The second
pillar of Islam. No. No. But you study
Islam more than you study the Bible
probably. That's not true. Probably.
Yeah. Okay. The second pill of Islam is
salah. Okay. So to us to
establishahill first is important
anyways. So once we establish that the
truth is already solidified. Okay. But
is prayer. Okay. I can understand what
you're saying. It's clear. How do you
how do you establish that? Okay. You're
teaching them. You guys 15 15 $20 $20 I
have to I'm fundraising. I'm funraing.
I'm raising. But this is how this is how
you're supposed to do it. This is how
you're supposed to pray. Yeah. If the
prophets didn't do this, if the prophets
didn't teach this, why teach to we just
showed you a Orthodox Christian, he
prays similar to that. Talking about
praying to Jesus. Do do you accept that
Moses, Jesus, Adam, and all these
prophets prayed? Of course. But they
pray. They do. We know how they pray.
It's who they prayed to. Do we know how
they prayed? Sometimes they prostrated.
Sometimes they looked up to the sky.
Yeah, I I do that as well. Sometimes I
looked up to the sky as well. You're
able to look up to the sky during
yourself? Yeah, you can. No, not in
salah. Like dua. Du salah. Okay. So, why
not? So, I can make dua anytime anyway.
I can make dua now. Oh, Allah guide no
logic to Islam. Why can't you look up
during salah? Huh? Why can't you do look
up to salah is specified. So, salah is
because it's specified to tell us that
we shouldn't look around. We have a
hadith that tells us when you're praying
don't look around. So, we have
instructions. So, okay. So, the prophets
didn't have this ruling when it came to
their praying. They just we don't know
that. We don't know that prophets. No,
no. You know what was given to Abraham?
We we how to pray. Nothing was given to
Abraham. We just we just saw through the
Torah how Abraham prayed and
communicated with God. So, how did
Abraham pray? Free. It was very free.
You know the Jews prostate once a year.
Where is that in scripture? No. No. They
they do that. I don't care what I don't
care about that. I'm talking about the
the prophets and but you follow a lot of
stuff that's not in scripture. They
don't believe you. You say a lot of
stuff that's not in scripture. What does
that do with? Cuz you said I said Jews
prostrate once a year. You said but
that's not in scripture. Yeah. Oh yeah.
And I said you follow a little stuff but
it's not scripture. Yeah. That's a like
what? That Jesus is God.
Said the Bible and like Muslim. You had
a debate with him. Yeah. And you did say
I did try guys. You tried your best.
Yeah. What are you talking about? He
said that Jesus is God in a sense. He
said Jesus is Have you seen a debate
with Muslim? I should call him. I was
like call him. Yeah. Ask him if Jesus is
Yahweh. No. No. No. No. He said to you.
He said Jesus is in a sense. You've been
avoiding this debate. Tell Ask him ask
him is Jesus. He said that you've been
avoiding this debate. By the way, guys,
we're we're 162 away from our target.
Why Why you saying the Bible doesn't say
that? One second. Let me see what he's
saying.
Your your teacher says shut up. Liiano
says that Jesus is your way in a sense.
He didn't pick up. All right. Holy
Spirit. Hello. I'm I'm here with Mr. Mr.
Mr. Logic. He wants Let me know. Yeah.
Yeah. He wants to talk about the other
debate he's been. I don't want to talk
to him. I'm talking to you. Oh, he's
talking to me. He's talking to me. Yeah.
But but do you agree with him that Jesus
is that he's saying he's saying is that
my son? Do you do you agree that Jesus?
I don't know what he's saying. One
second. No. Answer the question. No, no,
no, no. I work completely different,
bro. So then why are you saying what
he's saying? I wanted to speak to him.
No, no, no. First you speak to him. I'm
talking to you. I come here for him. No,
after I can talk to him after the way he
did you in the debate, I would want to
talk to the if I was you, I would block
him. admitting that Jesus is Yahweh.
Look, do you agree with that?
Bro, I don't know if you agree with him,
bro. He's here. He's helping me fund
raise. He's helped us raise
5600,00 Let's see if you agree. Do you
agree with him? You have a question for
him. Do Do you agree with him? Do you
agree that Jesus is I need you to tell
me if you're going to Are you going to
accept that? Do you agree with Jesus?
Are you going to accept that debate?
I'll answer this question. What? What
debate? What's the debate called? Do you
agree? I'm just trying to see if you
agree. There we go. You are you going to
accept the debate dynamic question? I
I'll answer this question. I'll answer
if you answer to me. Okay.
Mine's a yes or no. So is mine. Yes or
no? Do you agree with Libyan that Jesus
is Yahweh in Alles?
Huh? He said in the debate you said he
couldn't in the same in the same debate.
He said no. You're going to talk to me.
I know. No separate. Answer my question.
I'll answer yours. I promise. No. You
have my word, bro. He said that he Are
you going to accept it? Are you going to
accept debate? Are you going to accept
that debate? Answer my question. Are you
going to accept the debate with me? Do
you agree with all Muslims? If you agree
with the Orthodox, I'm my own man. I'm
my own man. I'm saying I'm saying All
right. I'm asking you. Will you take
that debate? The Christians I never
visit Islamics anymore. I'm asking if
you answer me. Let's get him off the
phone. If you answer me a yes or no on
this, I will answer him on this
question. Bro, it's not he's not his
answer. You ready? I I don't blame him,
bro. I don't blame you. I don't agree
with him and I'll give you an answer to
the debate. No, it's not.
You don't need to answer this question,
bro. Yeah. No, I'm all mine. I'm all
mine. Okay. Okay. I I'm I'm I'm not
answering. Okay. Answer me. Okay. No. If
you can't answer me, I can He's saying
if you don't answer me, I'm answering. I
think that's fair. He's he's upset. He's
upset. Fair, right? He's his side. He's
upset. He's upset. Let me speak to him.
Make
sure you agree with him that Jesus is
Yahweh. Okay. Okay. Let me let me talk
with him.
Okay. Okay. All right. So, he doesn't
want Okay. So, he doesn't he doesn't
want to debate him. is a Christian
dilemma. Now, you don't want to say that
you have no before that. Before that, no
one second. One second, brothers and
sisters. He's his own man. His own man,
brothers and sisters, as your own man.
We need we need look look brothers and
sisters, I want people to donate, okay?
We've got Look, let's see. Let's see.
And hey, brothers and sisters, donate if
he answers the question. Guys, we are we
need we need 10 people. 10 people 50.
I'll donate.
50. Yeah. No, no. I want to be scan
scan. Scan scan scan. Scan agree with
Muslim. Scan.
Scan. I'll donate if you agree with
orthodox. First donate. Do you agree?
First donate. I thought so. Do you
agree? I thought so. I thought so. I
thought so. I thought so. Do you agree,
guys? We're 162 away. Do you agree?
We're 162 away. You can teach someone
how to pray salah. What you got? You
can't got to teach. Look. Look. There.
There. Yeah. Look. Alhamdulillah.
There you go. Yeah. Scan it. Scan. We
got We got scan.
Scan. Muslim. If you agree, I I'll put
50 in there. 50.50. You see? If you
agree. You know what? I've got a message
for the Muslims. Even Christians are
donating. If you agree, Muslims.
Muslims. Because we got a Muslim who's
agreeing that Jesus is a Even Christians
are donating.
Muslims, it's we've got Christians even
believe in the cause. We got Muslims
even. We've got no logic. They believe
in the cause. Muslims believing that
Jesus is. Look guys, look. Amen. They
are even converting day by day.
Subverting brothers and sisters. Look.
See? Hallelujah. Get this man. Get this
man. A Christian is dominating.
With
and yes, I am a Christian. A Christian
donated to the cause. I will not donate
unless you Muslims believe. Look, our
Christian brothers, our Christian
brothers, believe in I'll donate, too.
And he's going to donate and he's going
to donate. But you guys are not donating
too if you agree. I think the donation's
coming out. £100. I just need an answer.
I just need an answer. I just need an
answer. You guys are fantastic. 300,
brother. How's the debate done? Some
someone said one second. No. Somebody
said, "Bro, brother, no logic is a great
co-undraiser."
Alhamdulillah. Brothers and sisters,
brothers and sisters, carry on donating,
don't forget to donate. Alhamdulillah.
Brothers and sisters, we need now 10
people. Look, it says, "Brother, no
logic is a great
co-friendraer." Co- funer.
Alhamdulillah. They help us. They
believe in the cause. Alhamdulillah.
Let's go.
We are now 62 pounds away. So we have to
thank You know what Allah says? Allah
says be thankful. Now he's going.
Where's he going? Come back. Come back.
No. Come back. Come back. Now come back.
Come back, bro. We need you. How's he
going to come back? We need you. How is
he going to come back? No logic. No
logic. You're not answering. Where is he
going? Where is he
going? Where's Where's he going, bro?
Where is he going? We just got started.
We just got started.
Where you going, brother? Come back.
Where you going? There you go. He's
quit. He's already quit. He's already
quit. I knew. I knew. I knew. He was
nervous when he came. Check. He's
already gone. Look. Another £5. £5. £30.
He left. He left and went. Look. Was
doing so well. The Christians were about
to donate. And look, even my cozer. Yo
yo yo yo yo yo yo yo. Come on. Come on.
Come on. Come on. Let's try it. Come on.
Come go come go come go come go come go
come go come go come go come go come go
come go come go. Hey hey hey. Hey, hey,
go, go. Yeah, yeah. Table, table, table,
table, table, table, table. Please,
please, table. Come on, man. The
donation is a bit slow. I need Yo,
listen. This guy, big up to this guy.
Last time he made this raise, nearly
£3,000. We got some guy's fantastic
in the Quran in surah 5. Yeah. Verse 48.
Yes. It tells you that apparently. Are
you okay? Why you moving about? You got
the Holy Spirit in you. Um in the Quran
I can move. So he tells you apparently
that Allah made three communities three
trinity with three. No just three
separate ones. Now he he said he could
have made them one but he didn't do it.
Now he told them apparently that you
have to have to compete uh with their
laws the Christians the Jews and the
Muslims for good works. Okay. And when
they return to Allah he will tell us
about where we used to differ. So that
means that the Quran is corrupt.
So that means that the Quran is saying
Babylon isn't corrupt. I I all I heard
was Allah says there are three
communities. If you return back to them,
they are not corrupt. You missed that
one part. He could have made them one,
but he didn't do it. That's what he
says. He could have made them one, but
he didn't do it. He didn't do it. And
that's your argument, right? No, no,
that's more than that, right? But
additionally, he tells them to compete
with each other for good works. Where's
it going? He's upset. So that means that
I am supposed to read my Bible and
compete with you a Muslim for good
works. Oh, you have the engine. So that
would then mean that if we didn't have
the angel, there'd be no way could
actually make us looking for it all this
time. Good works. We've been looking for
all this time for whatever it is that we
have to be the angel. So therefore Ali
that would mean that the angel. So when
Jesus was going and preaching the
gospel, was it Mark, Matthew, Luke, or
John? Okay. Oh yeah, it was for
example receiving his wahi. Is that a
donation?
€119. I told you they donate when he
brother listen. Thank you. Thank you.
When when
when the Muslim app was this entire
receiving he's upset by no logic is
upset by the way and he's not talking to
me. He's not talking because she doesn't
actually have the ability by the way
interact. Well no he's not the angel by
the way. Wait if I have the angel when
Jesus was preaching the gospel. Exactly.
Was it Muhammad was having John's
gospel? Was
it writing? Whose gospel was it?
Exactly. Whose gospel all of this? All
you have is you
have they wrote down what he said. So
yes, hold on. So Jesus when he was
preaching the gospel, the gospel of
Matthew and John. So Alli just because
he destroyed Christianity. He just did a
Christianity destroyed. He just said
Jesus was preaching Matthew that came
later. Ooh, bro. They wrote it down.
They wrote down what he said. By logic,
do you like Japanese food? I recommend
somewhere for you. Her and tortoise.
What's it called? Her and tortoise. But
they'll be they're closed now tomorrow.
Can't talk with me. But the chicken is
only halal. I'm still waiting for you.
Behind the duck. This
inde If it was Christian, if it was a
Christian restaurant, I could have I
could have the beast. So, what wouldn't
that mean Ali? But it's not sadly when I
went to Brazil. I was having happiness.
I look committing. M was having happy
days going directly against the Quran
doesn't actually see how we get on. Look
how we get on this. Exactly. But we're
Christians. We're cool, man. Why have
you making look we're not cool? These
brothers helping us fund raise. They're
donating. We're teaching Christians to
come to Islam, how to praise
Allah that the Islamic miracles were
actually a lie. The scientific miracles
were alive. So therefore, now on live
TV, say I I I want everyone to see this.
Hey Ali, are you confirming that indeed
we're having a heart? We're having a
heart to heart right now. Is the one
that is available today? We're having a
heart to heart right now, guys. You're
confirming that. Just just making sure.
I I don't know what he's talking about.
I think he's talking. He said that he
now believes that the in the Quran is
actually the one that the Christians
have today. Thank you. You know what?
Can I say something to you? Because he
didn't say right. Right. Didn't Jesus
say he with no still cast the first
stone? Uh uh. No. He's no sin. No still.
Sin sin. Try again. Try again. Okay. He
He with no sin cast the first stone.
Exactly. Did he say that? Exactly. So
then Did he say that? Now did he say
that? If he said this, did he say it?
Why does Muhammad prescribed stoning for
people? No, no, no, no, no, no, no. Does
Muhammad not have sin? Yes, he does. In
Surah 48:1 and 2, it says what? Oh
prophets, you know, we No, listen guys,
a good guys listen better than me. I'm
almost there. He's better than 48.
What does the law say? He says that oh
by prophets we forgive you for your for
your sins. So to worry not about them
because we forgive you for your past and
your present sins. So if Muhammad
prescribed stoning for adultery and he
had sin that would then mean that
Muhammad was going against the words of
Jesus by casting a stone against an
adulterer. Okay. So that mean Jesus came
to for it. Last one. If Muhammad goes
against Jesus, yeah, that means he's
literally the antichrist. Okay, that's
how do you respond? Very simple, simple,
simple question. Go for it. Go for it.
You know the antichrist, which is the
anti- messiah, right? Maybe you would
like to add this. No, no, no. Come on.
Come on. You know that you know the
antichrist? The anti- messiah, right?
Yeah. The anti- messiah. Okay. Who who
is that according to discussing? No. Is
he Is he going to be a man? Well, is
Muhammad a man? Is he going to be a man?
Is Muhammad a man? Yes. Yes, he's a man.
Okay. Okay. So tick, he's going to be a
man now. Is he going to be a man that
goes against the things of Jesus?
We agree he's going to be a man. Yeah.
Is he going to be a man that goes? Okay.
He's going to be a man. Is he going to
Is he going to claim to be divine? Well,
hold on a second. Is he going to be a
man that goes against the things of
Jesus? He's going Is he going to be
divine? He's going to claim to be
divine. Well, hold on. If someone is
claiming to be the ner of Allah or or
the the last of of the of the messengers
and the prophets hold or that they can
divide moons or have water spread out
their hands. Sounds pretty divine to me.
How many humans do you know who can do
that? So, you know what? Let's say yes.
He knows. He knows. He knows he won't go
out. Now, let's say yes. He knows he
won't go out, brother. on earth. The
antichrist will be a man who will claim
to be divine. Now, what does that bring
you to mind? Wait, hold on a second. Let
me You spoke. Let me speak. At least
this guy listen. He said the problem was
Let me finish. Let me finish. I haven't
spoken yet. Let me
talk. Look, we have Time Square in it. I
went to New York. It's similar. You guys
are on steroids though. Okay. The
Antichrist will be a man who will claim
to be divine. No logic. Which religion
believes that God is a man? Hold on a
second. And that's what and claims to be
divine. Islam or Christianity? Islam.
Islam. So Islam believes that a man came
down and he will claim to be divine.
Yeah. You guys believe that Allah is
like a physical being. He's like a young
boy with curly hair. Okay. Again, we're
talking about it. It depends on the
source. We're talking about the
Antichrist. Boy with curly hair. We're
talking about Antichrist. He said Islam
is Antichrist. Yeah. Check this out.
Your mouth is going to drop. Now check
this out. The Antichrist is going to be
a man. Correct. Well, yeah. Is he going
to claim to be divine? Yep. Which
religion believes that God is a man that
claims him to be God? Islam.
Let me let me tell you why I'm saying
this. Brother, let me tell you why I'm
saying this, brother. Tell me why I'm
saying this, brother. Are you Muslims?
Do you believe God is a man? Let me tell
you why. Let me tell you why. Let me
tell you why. Let me tell you why I'm
saying this, bro. Did you hear that? The
reason why I'm saying this is because
look, listen. The reason why I'm saying
this is because So, we believe Allah is
a man. Well, yes. Look, there's a reason
why I'm saying this. Listen, listen. I'm
There's a reason why I'm saying this.
The reason why I'm saying this is
because look, it says that um Muhammad's
going to be afraid that, you know, you
guys are going to be confused about the
about the antichrist. And he says so
that you're not conf confused, the
antichrist is going to be, you know,
hentoed, curlyhaired, short, right? And
to know that the way that you know the
difference between him and your lord is
that your lord is not oneeyed. So to
know the difference between Allah and
the antichrist is that Allah is not one
eye. No, it's not only that. That's what
that's what the hadith say. It's not
only that though. Okay. Well, that's one
of the
discrimin that though. Okay, fine. So,
if there's more things if there's more
things then the only difference is is
that so do you mind just for the So, so
basically everything is everything is
virtually identical outside of that he
has that your Lord doesn't have one eye.
He has more than one eye. Okay. What do
you think? Eight eyes like a spider or
like two eyes like a man? Which one we
do? We don't believe in a spider or a
man. Your faith can go there.
Spider-Man. N sorry. Anyways, so now now
guys, okay, look, I asked a simple
question guys. Yeah, but we didn't get
an answer from you
because if I jump in, sorry. So Ali,
Ali, where are we getting our
description of the anti? I'm surrounded
by
safe. I'm good. You should love if we
had restaurant, we're going to eat
together. Don't forget 29. Let me let me
finish. They should come to No, let let
me let me let me go. Let me go. Where
are we getting our definition of the
antichrist from? From Islam or from
Christianity? Bible that has the actual
concept of the antichrist. Okay. So,
we're going to the Bible. Let me So,
what do we have? I haven't even spoken.
Let him talk. Let him talk. Let him
talk. Let him talk. We go read. We go
read one second. Ali, can you read? No.
Let him do his. There's definitely for
certain You can't read. You can't read
at all. Could you read? You can't read.
Okay. Now, guys, let's see. You know
what I love about Christians? They come
and go. Islam is an antichrist religion.
I go, "Okay, I mean, okay, let's put
that to the test." No, look, look, look,
the Hebrews said they're antichrist. No
problem. Let's go with it. Now, the
antichrist, we need to know a bit about
the antichrist cuz this is where this is
a full-blown knockout blow. Let me tell
you what, let
me now see I told you Allah says in the
Quran, they are not the same. He's a
good guy. This guy, he needs to learn.
Yes. Anyways, yes. But it's Allah. No,
not that one. They not like us. I'm not
talking about they don't like us. Yeah,
I'm talking about Allah says in the
Quran. The people of the book are not
the same. Some of them are good managed.
Anyways, what I'm saying is the
following. They come and say to us, no
logical will come and say to me, Islam
is Antichrist religion. No problem. I
guess that's unnecessary.
Sorry, he can't help himself. I'll give
him a good excuse. He's got the Holy
Spirit inside him. No problem. Now no,
no, no, no, no. He's moving mad. Okay.
Now, the antichrist is, let's put it to
the test, guys. The antichrist, we need
to know about the antichrist. Now, the
antichrist even in their scripture says
that it will be a man. A man, man, man.
What will this man claim? He will say,
"I am God." Now, I'm asking a very
simple question. I don't even want to
shout. Which religion believes that God
came to earth and is a man and claims to
be living. Bro, there look, there's no
difference between Allah and look at the
camera. Look at Turn the camera to these
guys. Turn the camera, bro. The Muslims
are in shock because they don't know.
Guys, do you believe Jesus is God? Of
course. Do you believe that Allah is you
know you said do you believe Allah? No.
You asked, you remember you asked me, do
you pray? Do you believe that Allah? Do
you do you remember? Yes. Do you
remember you said to me, do you pray?
Whenever you said to me, do you praise
facing the heavens? I'm doing it now. Oh
Allah, help me. But will
Allah, guys, do you know why they're
avoiding it? Because they believe, let's
not shout over each other. They believe
I'm okay. Sorry. They believe They
believe I don't give any excuse. They
believe Jesus was a man. Was he a man?
He's both fully man, fully God. Okay. He
was a man. I believe Allah is and he is
God. Now I'm asking a simple question.
the antichrist when he comes back and
he's got powers because the Bible say
he's got powers. is going to do
something you know that no more people
can do and he comes and says I am God
the moon would the Christians or the
Muslims fall for his trap the Muslims
the Muslims the Muhammad says the
Muslims will fall for what are you
talking about I know that I'm talking
about generally I'm talking about that
if who believes God is a man in the
flesh the Christians are the Muslims
okay hold on look I'm going with you
Christian we Christians believe sister
do you not believe Jesus is a
flesh don't buy into
to whom you don't need to buy anything.
He's using you as a distraction. Listen,
I know she has to
be the church. It's not the church.
Don't do it. Don't do it. Is
Jesus do that right now? There is three
parts to God. God, the father listen.
She's not in the church. She said to be
quiet. In the church, the Lord the
father, God the father, God the son, and
God the holy spirit. Now listen to us.
We're made of three parts. body, soul,
and spirit. And when God came, God sat
on the throne and allowed his son to
come to earth.
Yeah. To redeem man. To redeem man. To
redeem man. There was And to redeem man.
And he became flesh. Okay. God. Yeah. A
sincere Christian who just preached the
gospel. She said clearly a a a a a a a a
a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a
a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a in flesh.
He came in flesh. He became
he became so divinely because there was
no other seed that could be pure enough
to represent him. No, no, just my
question please. Therefore, the
antichrist question. The antichrist is a
man that claims to be divine and the
only religion that believes God is a man
and that is divine is is Christianity.
So then answer this question. It's
Christianity. So why does Muhammad So
why does Muhammad say that the Muslims
will get confused with him? Hold on. Why
do why do the Muslims say guys y'all
helping him distract? Y'all helping him
get away. Stop letting them get away.
Y'all be quiet. All right. Now y'all,
what y'all What's the donation y'all? So
the question is the question is if the
if if Muslims are not the ones who
believe that God took on flesh and
became man, it's only the Christians.
Why is it then that the Muslims
according to Muhammad will get deceived
by the dal? Exactly. Because not only
that, the hadith says that he will have
kufur written in his head. So what? So
not let me finish. Not only that, there
will be a boy that will come to him and
he will get the boy and slice him in
half and put him back together cuz he
has those powers. We believe the
antichrist will have those powers. And
let me You guys don't believe I'm
finished. He will say, "Do you now
believe I am your Lord?" And he will
say, "Rather now I believe further
you're not my Lord." Why? Because there
are Muslims who look, we have Muslims
today who fall into. There are Muslims
who go to the grave. They go to the
grave of the prophet Muhammad and think
the prophet Muhammad can help him.
What's your point? Now, the point is is
here though. The Antichrist religion is
what? Christianity because they're the
ones that believe God is a man. Okay.
So, now let me respond to you on this.
With no disrespect, sister. I'll just No
disrespect. Yeah. Yeah. Just no
disrespect. Let me respond now. Let me
let me respond. What is it? Yeah. Yeah.
Now, now this is now now this is the
confusion here and he let me thank you.
I just let you now notice the confusion
here. According to Muhammad, according
to Muhammad, it's the Muslims that will
be confused about the
Djal. Okay, but that's what Muhammad
says. But listen, let me tell you what
Muhammad doesn't say that you'll be
deceived by his m by his powers and the
miracles that he does. He says so that
you don't get him confused with your
lord. So that you don't get the man the
dal the antichrist who's a man confused
with Allah which I don't know how you'll
do it because Allah is not a man right
you get confused let me land it let me
land it okay if you if if just so that
you don't get confused the antichrist
with the djal he's hento he's
curlyhaired he's short but just know
that your lord is not oneeyed he is
oneeyed but Allah he's not one eyed
that's how you can tell the difference
okay so they're virtually identical.
Mhm. They're identical. You see where
this is coming from? Because they
believe God, do you not? No. Because you
believe God is a man. You This is why I
don't blame you. Because Because you
believe God is a man, you have to apply
that to everything you see. All you see
is the Trinity. All you see is fully
man, fully God. Let me tell you, let me
tell you what. Because you've looked at
the narration that says hair and this
that. You're thinking, "Hey, we believe
God is a man. Hair, eyes. Oh my gosh,
that sounds like Jesus. Oh no, Muslims
believe in that as well." Nice try. What
I would do is you don't believe he has
hair. Why do is this though? Can you
imagine? Muslim, do you believe Allah
has curly hair? No. I don't care about
what they believe. I care about what the
hadith is. Guys, guys, guys, please.
Well, this is this is your best
argument. No, but I'm I'm talking to
you. You're not what I'm saying. Did you
come all the way from America? I came
all the way with this curly argument. I
came all your arguments are curly. I
need to straighten them out. Okay. Can
you give me your arguments are curly,
bro? Uncurly. I'm trying to straighten
it. All right. So, straight. And by the
way, there's nothing but curly hair.
Okay. So, so what's the problem? What's
the problem? Let me tell you about the
problem. By the way, hold on. You know
what I'm going to do? Why does he give
this? You know what I'm going to do? You
know what I'm going to do? has curly
hair. These ones short. You know what
I'm going to do? Let me do this. Yeah.
Let's put Christianity and Islam to
aside. Oh my goodness. I just want you
to deal with something. I'm Look, I'm
going to deal with one thing and you're
not going to forget this for the rest of
your life. And we're going to we're
somewhere where it looks like Time
Square, but it's not. Piccadilly circus.
Remember this date. What's the date
today? The 31st of May. It's 11:30. I'm
just waiting on him to touch on what I
said. I just want to know why is it that
he and Allah are identical. Okay, let's
let's let's let's have a first disc.
Let's have a fair discussion of the
enemy is deception. It's deception.
That's how the enemy deceives. And and
do you know the only way you can know
Jesus? Through him revealing himself to
you and you have to accept him. It's so
si sister, what is the wage of sin? Yes.
Why are you turning away? And blood
sacrifice. Why are you turning away? Who
does blood? No, no, no. The blood. Yes.
Yes. So, so, so can I say no? She asked
me. No, she asked me a question. You
switched to her. You switched to her.
Focus. Sister, I'm not going to come to
you cuz they're blaming me. Forgive me.
Yes, I'm blaming you. So, focus. It came
from them. I don't think I'm ignoring
it. Okay. So, this is what I need you to
do. Wait, wait. I'm going to give you
the mic. In Christianity, I'm going to
give it to you. They believe in the wage
of sin is death. When she deal with the
Are you married? Can you deal with the
Are you married? When your wife gives
birth when your when your wife gives
birth, are you are you guys married?
Yes, we're married. Call me to come to
your wedding. I'm going to come to your
wedding now. But can you when your wife
gives birth and she's in pain, she's
she's suffering what? Can you answer the
question? What do you mean exactly? Can
you answer the question? I'm asking you
a question. You're asking Islam. In
Islam, there is no The wage of sin is
death. There is no blood sacrifice. We
don't eat flesh. You have repented you
sin. You repent. Okay. How did
Alhamdulillah? How did Allah ransom?
Alhamdulillah. How did Allah, brothers
and sisters, how did Allah I'm going to
give you. How did Allah ransom Abraham's
son? If you can prove to me Christianity
is the truth, I'm going to accept
Christianity. I'm going to accept
Christianity today. You begin. If you
can prove to me that Jesus is God, I'm
going to accept Christianity. Oh,
really? I'm going to give you I'm going
to give you an argument.
And if you can do cuz this argument is
fair. Yeah. Where's Where is it? Where
is it? Where is it? He said if I can
prove that Jesus is God, he going to
Wait, have you got it? Have you got
camera? Oh, the battery had in the wrong
time. Anyway, back up. Back up cameras.
Yes. Alhamdulillah. Now they even have
to copy us. Allah have the word. Okay.
Now brothers and sisters, I'm going to
give an argument that is going to be
fair. Totally fair. Do you mind your
camera's getting in the way of our
camera? Sorry. Sorry. Okay guys, I'm
going to give him the argument from
contingency. And if he proves through
this argument, a counterargument, this
is not about Islam. It's not about
Christianity. We're moving out. Do you
know how you left the conversation? No,
I'm still in the conversation. No, but
you left about the versus. Yes, we
already deal with that. What? We haven't
done. You said Allah has curly hair and
I said the arguments are curly. I'm
trying to strike. This is what I asked
you. Look, this is what I asked you. We
done with that. That's done. No, but you
didn't answer my question. Of course, I
answered. Okay, look. I You know what?
If you just answer it, I won't even
argue with the I answered it. I told you
that the man who came and he split him
in half. He said rather I know now more
than you know my daughter. That's not
what I'm asking. I'm asking about this
particular Okay. I'm going to Okay.
Yeah, sir. I'm asking specifically about
what Muhammad said on why he's worried
that you guys will get him
confused with Allah. He's worried about
it. Okay. And so he then begins to
describe what the djal looks like and
gives the difference with Allah. So he
says the the dal's hento curlyhaired
short. However, just know that your lord
is not one eye. So the way you tell the
difference according to Muhammad is that
Allah is not oneeyed like the dal is.
Everything else though virtually
identical. That's what you had. That's
what I understood. How do you break that
down? The only reason you understand
that from the hadith is because you're a
trinitarian that believes God is fully
man and fully God.
So when you believe God is a man, when
you believe chicken,
when you believe God is a man, you see
him everywhere. So when the hadith says
he's thinking yo Jesus now I'm
explaining the hadith says what the
young boy came to him and when he split
him in half did he say hold on a second
the splitting me in half was not the
issue because you're not one eyed that's
not the hadith I'm talking about another
hadith I know I'm asking about this one
but but I'm telling you you don't take
it in isolation okay so at least break
this when I quote the Bible you don't
say Ali just the top one verse we take
it in context this has nothing to do
with that context so now these are two
completely different context Listen,
can you tell Sam? By the way, tell him
that it's closed in a half now. When
it's back on the back, we're still here,
but tell him to move the D table. Now,
can we have a discussion? These guys are
talking. Now, brothers and sisters, I
want to go to the argument because the
cross of this matter of our difference
is Islam or Christianity. Okay, that's
that's the cross of the matter. Okay.
Now notice how you didn't you didn't do
I I I answered and I said I answered and
I said the man who got split in half
when he was brought back he did not say
because you have two eyes you're not my
lord. He said now I'm further know that
you're not my understand. Can you
explain? That's another can you explain
why Muhammad describes these differences
and says your lord is not one. That
shows that number one we know from
Islam, the Quran and the Sunnah that
Allah is not a man. So then why would
they get confused? But why does he break
this? Look, look, look, look. He didn't
say you get confused. He literally does.
He's given a description and the man who
got split in half knew by the show. I
know already. Okay, so you know what
says that they'll get confused. Look,
you're running away from the You're
running away from the argument. You're
okay. Now I'm asking a simple question.
So we're done with it. Let's let's This
already done a long time ago. Allah has
curly hair. You forfeited this. No
problem. You forfeited it. I gave up. I
quit. I know. I know. No problem. Let's
move on. Okay. Now guys, an argument for
contingency. This is an argument that
Yes. Yes. Now, Christianity, Islam, all
religions aside, logic and rational
logic. Okay. Alhamdulillah. Okay. And
this is from the Quran. This argument is
from the surah. Anyways, now why this
guy's shouting, bro? Can I can we go a
bit further there? Sam. Yeah, we can.
Sam. Sam. Sam. Sam, please, bro. Please
sit up. Okay, guys. Now, I want to know
if Jesus Hey, the party just started,
bro. What's going on? Y'all trying to
Oh, sorry.
Y'all trying to go. Okay. Anyways,
listen y'all. Okay. Now, brothers and
sisters, this argument is going to fully
fully
establish tohed or trinity. Period. He
defines. Now, now brothers and sisters,
let's go. Now, brothers and sisters, the
first thing I'm going to say is this.
There are three types of existence.
Three types of existence. There's three
types of existence. Okay? There is
impossible existence. Impossible
existence. Yes. There is possible
existence. There's possible existence.
And there is necessary existence. All
right. What what define like I'm going
to give you the definition. Yeah. Give
me an example of an impossible
existence. Okay. So there are three
types of existence. Okay. Impossible
existence is like having a triangle
square. So does it exist? No. So it
doesn't exist. It's an impossible
existence. So it doesn't exist. No, it
won't exist. You can't have a triangle
square. So then there's only two types
of existences right now. No, we're going
to come to that. We're doing it bit by
bit. Oh yeah. We just eliminated one of
them. Yeah. Yeah. That's the whole
point. were eliminated to to come to.
Okay. Okay. The first one is an
impossible existence. Why? How many
sides does a triangle have? Three. How
many sides does a square have? Four. So
that's why it's an impossible existence
cuz you're going to have a triangle
square. So it doesn't exist. It doesn't
exist. Okay. So that's not an existence.
Yes. But bear in mind, I'm going to come
to the triangle square a bit later, but
it doesn't exist. Now we have two types
of existence left. Okay. The the the uh
possible existence is for example me you
our planet, our solar system, uh the
sun, the galaxies, etc. Why? My
definition of a contingent being a
possible existence is that something
that relies on something else for its
existence. It can be composed of pieces
and it can be any other
way. So that means I am dependent, you
are dependent, our planet is dependent,
the sun is dependent, the galaxies are
dependent. Right? Now we cannot have an
infinite regress of dependent things. Do
you agree? Yes. Okay, good. So we say
that there has to be a necessary being
that is not how would you define
dependence? Okay. So dependency is
something that relies on something else
for it existence. It can be composed of
pieces and it can be any other way.
Good. Good. So we say that you cannot
have an infinite regress of dependent
things which means we need a independent
necessary being that cannot be any other
way and cannot be composed of pieces.
Got it. Perfect. Now be composed of
pieces. Yes. All right. Good. Now,
was Jesus dependent or independent? He's
independent. He's independent. Yes.
Okay. So, my definition of dependency
was something that relies on something
else for it existence. Yeah. You you
said something that relies on another
exist. It can be any other way and it's
and it's not composed of pieces. So, all
right. So, is all three of those. No.
So, when you talk you said dependence,
right? Dependence is relying on
something outside of your outside of
your being, right? No. depending on it
depends on it's your dependence requires
on something else for when you say
something else when you for example I
need water I need to sleep the the
planet needs the sun to be a perfect
distance so we don't freeze to death uh
the sun has it orbit let's try let's try
to make sure okay so the sun relies on
something outside of its own being to
for its existence right being it
requires something else to survive that
well that's that yeah that's outside of
it being that's outside of it being when
you say being what do you mean by that a
being is is it's it's ontology what it
is it's its existence. So so something
else that exists gives gives itself
existence. So another being which
is
brother that's please please let's so so
just to solidify so dependency is
something that relies on another being
for its existence or on another thing
for it existence. Can we can we can we
solidify on being? So would you say that
a thing is another I don't require a
water is not a being. I require water
water is a being water. So being is just
a is a state of existence. It has onto
if that's your definition of being then
yes. Okay. Cool. Yes. All right. Cool.
So so dependency you rely on another
being for your existence. All right
let's go on. That's my view. So you said
that Jesus is independent. Yeah. He's
independent. That is not independency
because Jesus is number one. Jesus could
be any other way. He could be any other
way. What did Jesus look like? I don't
know.
Is there anything else about you talking
about his human nature? Yes. Well,
you're talking about his divine nature.
No, I'm talking about his human nature.
What did he look like? I I don't know.
Did he have two arms? Yes, he did. Could
he been born with no arm? Uh, possibly.
Okay. So, he can be any other way. So,
he's dependent. Oh, yeah. But you're
talking about his human nature versus
his divine natur. No, no, no. I'm not
talking about human
nature. I'm saying Jesus. I would agree
that the human nature is dependent. I
would agree. But okay. Okay. If it's
dependent, then you cannot have an
independent regressive dependent thing.
It has to depend on something that is
independent. So what is the independent
thing? Uh Jesus's divine nature. So
because Jesus Let me finish. Let me
finish. Let me answer in full. Okay.
Because Jesus has a divine nature. He
has a a nature that is independent.
Okay. You can't be dependent independent
at the same time. Yeah. Well, I I agree
that you can't be dependent and
independent at the same time. In the
same sense, I'm not saying that Jesus is
independent in regards to his divine
nature, dependent in regards to his
human nature. But my argument is the
following. I told you there are three
types of existence. Imposed one of them.
triangle square if you if I'll give you
a little recap there. Let's say this cuz
the triangle and square distinct, right?
The triangle has three sides. The square
has four sides. So the triangle, let's
name the triangle Jesus. And let's name
the square the father. No, no, no. Let's
No, no, no. Wasn't it? No. Let's name
the triangle flesh and name the square
divine. No, no. Because you know why?
Because there are two separate composite
beings. Let me tell you, let me let me
let me finish. Let me finish. Let me
finish. Cuz you know where this going.
No. Yes. I'll be laughing if I was you,
too. I'll be laughing if I was you, too.
You know when the nerves come up you got
to you got to release it one it's either
by farting or laughing. Yes. Okay. So
now guys the the triangle and square are
two opposites. So I said an impossible
existence is what to have a triangle
where they're impossible. It's just the
same way of saying as dependent
independent. Okay two opposites black
white. So now and then I said there are
dependent things like myself I I depend
on water sleep shelter food and many
other things to survive. We I asked a
question is Jesus dependent or
independent? He said he's independent. I
said to him, "No, because Jesus when he
was born could have been born with one
with one arm missing." He said, "Yes."
That shows he's composed of pieces. He
could be any other way and he is
dependent. And I said it depends on
where he goes. He depends on his
independence. No. Can I can I respond to
this? All right. Thank you. So you're
you're conflating categories. So when
you ask me is Jesus dependent or
independent, I said independent. That's
in regards to his divine nature. He's uh
the dependency, the human nature is
dependent. Okay. It's composite. Of
course. Now you said that this is like
doing a a sorry this? Yeah, this is me.
You said you said that this is like
doing a squared circle. Now let me ask
you this cuz I agree with you that a
square and square and circle cannot be a
triangle square. Sorry. A triangle
square cannot be the same thing. Right.
Now let me ask you this. Can a triangle
and a square be put next to each other?
Yeah. Okay. Is that a contradiction? No.
Okay. So I'm not saying that the divine
nature and the human nature are
intertwined and mix and are the same
exact thing. I'm saying that they're
next to each other. They're united in
the person of Jesus next to No. No. When
you make them next when you mix them
next to each other united unite them as
one force of the triangle square that's
why I said it's an impossible existence
because you can't have triangle square
that's what I'm saying that's not a
triangle each other I have a triangle
and I have a square but you look like a
house it's like a square and a triangle
it's like a little house in it yeah but
doesn't work here because the house just
fell apart you know why because I'm
saying can you have a triangle square
he's saying no when you put the triangle
and square together if you look at it
guys it looks like a little house yeah
but the argument of houses fell apart
I'm saying the following because you're
saying can you have a square and
triangle put together? I said yes and it
doesn't contradict. I said can you have
a triangle square? Right? And I say no.
Right? So so look notice let's get on
the same page. Okay. You and I both
agree that you cannot have a triangle
and a square in the same way in the same
sense. Okay. We agree. What does that
remind you? Once you see that a second
I'll say it again. Sure. For the
audience. You cannot have a triangle and
a square in the same way in the same
sense. Wow. So understand You just said
Jesus and the father. Ali, follow what
I'm saying. Follow what I'm saying.
Okay. So, what I'm
saying? What I'm saying is is that we
have a triangle and we have a square
next to each other. United. Not that
they're mixed. Not that it's they're
combined. They're united in the person.
Okay? So, I'm not saying that Jesus is
independent and dependent in the same
exact way, in the same sense. That would
be a contradiction. I'm saying that he
has a nature that is independent and a
nature that is dependent. Two different
natures united in the person. That's
called the hypoatic union. This is
Christian theology. That's some that's
some that's some hypo hypoatic
nons. You don't know how to do it. So
wait wait
wait. Okay. So so now so now it's my
turn. Okay. So so when you so when you
talk about composite right when you talk
about composite I would agree that the
human nature is composite right? It has
soul mind you know arms legs and stuff
like that. The divine nature it's not.
It's not made up in parts. You are
different though. You believe in Allah.
You don't believe that Allah is made up
of a parts. But you believe he has a
hand. You believe he has a shin, right?
You believe he has eyes. And now you say
that these things are not like how you
understand or how you know you don't ask
the how. I understand. But here's my
question. Is Allah identical to his
hands? For example. Okay. So I finished.
Yes. Okay. So I asked him the question.
You guys heard it for yourself in the
beginning when he said yes. When he said
that they are not they cannot be the
same. If only he just changed the word
triangle to Jesus and the square to the
father that look all you have to do is
guys when he says triangle Jesus square
father it's over the game is over. You
know why? Because I'm telling he's
joining them together as one uh um like
they're distinct. He's saying that you
can have a square and you join them
together unification. I'm saying that
can you have a dependent independent
being? Yes or no? I just told you I
already answered that. Yes or no?
Independent. Notice how you didn't
answer my question. I am I am Can you
have a dependent independent what was my
question? I'm I'm saying to you very
clearly that a
depend listen you said that the square
and the triangle are unification. So
you're saying that the dependent and
independent came together and the person
exactly and I'm saying that goes against
my argument of contingency because
dependency is something that relies on
something else for it existence. Number
one number two it is composed of pieces.
Number three, he can't be any other way.
Now Jesus demonstrates that how he's
composed of pieces. You got to deal with
my question. He can be any other way and
he is dependent. All he's done is the
following. He goes, they're unified.
Meaning the following. Jesus is
dependent. Jesus is dependent. What did
I say and independent at the same time?
What did I say? Okay. So triangle square
impossible existence. Looks like we got
existence. So let me make my argument.
Let me finish. This is the reason why
why tohed and Islam make sense. That's
the reason why we have hundreds of
Christians coming to Islam in this
table. You know why? Because every time
we ask a Christian, why did you leave
Christianity? The first thing they say
is not morality. You know what they say?
Because no, no, not even. They don't
even see. They say we left because
there's no in Christianity. They say
because of the trinity. Because of the
trinity. Because of the trinity. You
know why? Because the reason why. No,
no, no. I'm not I'm making another
argument. We say you cannot have an
infinite regress of dependent things.
Everything dependent has to rely on
something that is independent and that
has to be one true God which is Allah.
Now you might come and say why Allah but
not Jesus. That's not what I asked. Can
I can I ask my own question? So I'm
asking you a question. No stop. You
already made your argument. Is he
dependent or independent? I already
answered this. No, you didn't. Okay.
I'll answer it again but this time. Yes.
You have to deal with my question. Okay.
Cuz you cuz you brought in I just did.
Okay. Okay. You feel like you just did.
We'll see. All right. So we'll do this
again. I'll say it for one last time so
it's not circular for our audience. cuz
they're going to get bored of, you know,
this whole thing. Okay. You have the
divine nature. You have the human
nature. You paying attention? Yeah.
Yeah. Have they packed the table? It's
closing. Yeah. That's fine. But we're
still here. Okay. Are you sorry?
I got you. I got you. So, all right. So,
you got the divine nature, got the human
nature. They're not mixed. They're not
intertwined. They're united in the
person. So, I'm not saying that the
divine nature is is not divine in the
same way. I'm not saying that the human
nature is divine at the same time. No,
I'm saying he has a he's fully human
nature, a fully divine nature, united in
the person of Jesus, a triangle and a
square next to each other, not
intertwined, next to each other as you
agree that that's not a contradiction.
Okay? Now, when I'm talking about the
dependency, the human nature is
dependent, right? It was made, it was
created at some point, but his divine
nature is eternal. It always existed.
Okay? And it's whole. is not made up of
parts. But you don't believe that Allah
has a hypoatic union. You don't believe
that Allah incarnated in flesh. You
believe Allah has one nature. So you
said that makes more sense than Trinity
and the hypoatic union. So if you're
talking about composite, my question is
this. Allah has hands. Allah has a shin.
Is Allah's hands are Allah's hands
identical to his shin? Okay. So you've
asked me the question. Yeah. That please
answer. So your question of Allah's shin
and his attributes last the first thing
is about the trial square look I affirm
I affirm that's why I said to you
composed of pieces I affirm Allah
subhana wa ta'ala's hands the way before
his majesty I affirm one of that problem
of that question my argument but my
argument is not identical because I'm
saying I'm saying no no
no hands identical listen to me listen
to me listen to me the following I'm
saying to you that when we're talking
about the triangle square you said they
they come together the the father and
the Jesus the the fully man fully god
there comes no no no I am when you say
the fully man and fully god in one
nature can you explain to me how does a
triangle the square come together what
do you call a triangle square coming
together I I will I'll explain that you
need to explain that next no I'll
explain like this no you got to you
promised you would answer I I am I I
just said to you it's a yes or no it's
not yes or no first you need are Allah's
hands identical to his first you need to
do is this okay I'm saying to you Allah
is not composed of peace
We don't we don't believe that. So is
his hand are his hands identical to each
other? We don't believe that. Listen
what I'm saying. So then answer this
question. You are not answering the
triangle square argument. I literally
dealt with that. No, you didn't. You
said when you bring them together. I'm
saying when you're not satisfied with my
answer. Thank you. If you're not
satisfied. Thank you. You know why? When
you have a you cannot have a triangle
and square come together. What shape
would that be? Wait. You can't have them
next to each other. Wait. I can I can
literally draw on paper. When did I say
next to each other? You literally said
when did I say next to each other? You
literally told me I said, but I'm saying
my argument is not next to each other.
Can you have a triangle square? It's all
good. I said, can you have a what do you
call it? What do you call it? What's the
shape called? Okay. Triangle and square
can come together. You can call it
whatever you want. So you said what is
the shape called? You said triangle
square. That's a triangle and a square
next to each other. They can be next to
each other. Yes, you did. It's on
camera. It's on your own stream. So you
It's on your own stream. Alhamdulillah.
You know it. I can see it's going to
happen. Muslim sister. Focus. Triangle
square. Focus with me. Can you have a
triangle square? Stop. I didn't say I
didn't say together. You already said
can you have a triangle? Can you have a
triangle and a square next to each other
and it's not I know that. I know. But I
never said that. I'm saying triangle
square together.
Dude, please. Okay. Look. Stop. Please.
Me and you. You got to deal with
question. We're standing next to each
other. You have to deal with the
question. The question, you said that
taled is better than the trinity and I
just demonstrated. So are okay. Are
Allah's hands identical with his shin?
Yes or no? No. What's your point? Okay,
good. So
what's not composed of pieces? We affirm
that. We affirm his hands. We affirm the
shin. We But they're not identical.
Those are different. Those are different
parts of them, right? No. No. You said
parts. I didn't say parts. Okay. So is
You said parts. You said they're not
identical. Okay. Let me Is Allah
identical to his We don't have parts.
That's what I'm saying. describing
exactly. So I'm asking a simple
question. This is what you're running
away from. Can you have a triangle
square not next to each other? I accept.
I accept. See, there you go. He knows.
Are you okay? He knows. He knows. This
is why I said you're no logic. I know
what you're no logic. You know why?
Alhamdulillah. I'd rather be I'd rather
be slow than no logic. At least it's
some logic. Now guys, square and
triangle can come together. Together
meaning not
intertwined. I'm asking him the question
and he knows very well. You agree with
that? A square and a triangle can come
together. Do you agree with that? Yes.
It would look like a house. Okay. So, a
square and a triangle could come
together without it being intertwined
and being the same thing in the same
sense. Of course not. You can draw it.
Okay. Exactly. But that's not what I'm
saying. But that's not what I'm saying.
I'm seeing how could anyone is saying
can you have a circle next to a square?
No. Of course you can. I'm saying nature
and a divine nature united in a person.
They're not the same thing. Listen,
listen, listen, listen, listen
carefully. Can you deal with my I am.
Look, look, look. You're not You're not
Look, and then answer the question.
Triangle has how many sides? We already
did this. We're not doing this again.
Three sides. I'll do it for three sides.
Not doing this again. A square has how
many sides? Four sides. Look, look,
guys. One is three. One is four. One
looks like this. One looks like
that. One, one looks like this. No, no,
guys. No. Okay. Now, seems no
Illuminati. Now, guys, can you think
about this? Look, he knows what's
coming. Look guys, I'm saying to him,
one has three sides, one has four sides.
One looks totally different pattern.
Totally different shape. You don't
debate now. Now, alhamdulillah, you
brother, it's very clear. It's very
clear, bro. You're the one who run away.
Alhamdulillah. Yeah, you bro over there.
You alhamdulillah, I came to you.
Please, all respect, please. Please,
man, you quit, brother. Let's go. Now,
I'm asking you a simple question. I
asked you from the beginning, what is an
impossible existence? I said a triangle
square, not a triangle next to a square.
So an impossible existence which is what
independent dependent the flesh the body
the flesh is dependent but the godly
nature is independent my friend we call
that an oxymoron we call that a
contradiction we call that black and
white because they are two total
opposites and our argument is what for
Islam if something is dependent which
Jesus is dependent what does he depend
on he depends on the independent being
that is not made of He says is not
cannot be any other way and is
necessary. That was my argument and he
knew the moment he said Jesus is
dependent the question I asked was who
does he depend on? He depends on the
independent being which is Allah. This
is why it makes perfect sense. Okay.
Thank you. Any last words? Yeah last
last words here. Um um when you say that
Allah's shin is not identical to his
hands for example. Now you have just
acknowledged that Allah has division
within himself and has parts. His hands
is one part of him. his shin is another
part of him. And you I think he would
also say that his eyes are not identical
to his shin. Um that his his his face is
not identical to his back. So you
believe in a composed god. You your is
mixed up with a contingent being. Not
only that, but your Quran says that
Allah can't even have a son unless he
has a mate. So he's dependent. He could
have a son if he wanted to. The Quran
says this, he could have a son if he
wanted to, but Allah can't have a son
unless he had a mate, somebody to have a
son with. So your god is dependent and
made of parts. Your very own argument
destroys Allah Allah.
Okay. Tahed is over. Is it time to go?
You finished is over. Close. No. Here.
Here. Done. Wait. Let me let me land
this here. Let me land this here. So you
know you never flew to land. Wait. I've
been flying this whole time. Man, I've
been flying this whole time. I'm
carrying you, man. I've been carrying
you this whole time. Carry. I'm going to
set you down slowly, though. But so what
you're missing, Ali Dawa, is I I I mean,
I don't know. I think you might get it,
but you're probably purposely not doing
it for the audience. Like, you're
literally not dealing with what I'm
saying because you said what I'm saying
is not what you're saying, which is our
point. What you're saying is not what we
believe. Okay? You got to deal with our
belief. Don't straw man it. So, but
you're unable to engage. Straw man.
There's no man. It is. Well, actually,
mango. Okay. So, when you That's our
law. So when you when you can't engage
with my actual position and you haven't
been able to engage with it at all
tonight, that shows that you have to
misrepresent my position to have an
argument. That means you don't have an
argument. And then you're I I guess like
projecting contingency onto me as but
you're a Muslim. You're you you're a
Muslim. You believe that Allah has hands
and feet and chin and eyes and a back
and they're all different parts of uh
from each other. They're not the same
thing. So your Allah is contingent. He's
dependent and made up of parts. Not like
the triune God. So understand the
hypoatic union and then you'll do better
next time. Finished. Yeah. I told you
that's what the argument told me.
Alhamdulillah. One God, man. One man.
Guys, one God, no partners, not a man,
not not independent, guys. All you have
to do is just watch the video and you
know triangle. Just call triangle Jesus
and square call it the father and the
argument makes perfect sense dependent
independent I'm not going to lie man
some people I thought it was going to be
better arguments bloody hell man I knew
you wasn't going to be better arguments
you didn't disappoint there's god logic
who believes in one god there's dog
logic who obeys one master and there's
no logic free trinity and there's
slow argument good logic one god even a
dog even a dog has one master
there if you give a dog
He will obey you about the charity
rather than his no logic free. Right
guys, just watch the video.
Alhamdulillah. Let's go to our donation.
Let's get Yeah. 100% watch. Let's go,
brothers and sisters. Watch that video.
Alhamdulillah. Let's go. Let's go. Let's
get the donations. Let's go. Let's go.
Let's go. You
got alhamdulillah. Let's full donation
full. What's that? Okay. Donation.
Donation. Okay. Brothers and sisters.
Alhamdulillah. Whose mic? Whose mic is
this? Whose mic is this? Okay. Okay.
Okay. Brothers and sisters. Okay. Sure.
Let's get back to our Let's go go go. I
am a Rever and I was taught how to pray
salah. That means every single time I
pray, the person who told me gets the
reward five times a day from fud to Isa.
If you want to support someone like me
in learning salah, then sponsor 10
people for just $100 this Ramadan.
Remember the prophet peace be upon him
said, "Charity does not decrease wealth.
Click the button and donate now.